Jim is with us in Tennessee hi Jim
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey how
you doing better than I deserve
how can we help 29 years old have lawn
and landscaping business well have had
I'm currently in the middle of a truck
and my commercial mower being reason
enough and just trying to get some
guidance I've got about between eight
and ten thousand dollars of other
miscellaneous death between medical
bills and old old collections accounts
and things like that we don't want to
you don't want to go towards the
bankruptcy side by any means but the
banks law firm is very aggressive in
trying to collect the remaining by halle
how far behind are you on your payments
on your mower in your truck the mower I
have about thirteen hundred behind how
many payments that's about six payments
why are you six payments behind if
you're not been cutting grass I did up
until right at the end of last season
and then it's over here it slowed down
for us at about I would say I'd say
somewhere right before October it really
started slowing down and then by the
time that mowing season had started the
bank had oiled the bank's law firm had
threatened the press charges of
hindering secured creditor and when as
far as having a detective with the local
police department call me and tell me he
was going to arrest me for it so I
showed up they had already gotten the
truck at that point and I showed up with
the mower and the tow truck driver said
well the serial number on the mower you
now does not match the mower serial
number that the bank has on file and
they called the place where I purchased
the mower
I wish the loan that I've gotten from
the bank and the place I purchased the
mower said this is the mower he
the one you all have on file is actually
had actually been sold to somebody else
if the break has never updated their
paperwork to pay the tow truck driver to
drop them over off the tow truck and he
said he couldn't take it but it's
currently being stored at the place
where I purchased the mower okay so stop
a minute so why did what were you
planning you new grass was not going to
be cut in the winter right so how were
you planning to pay the mortgage the
mower payments knowing that I the last
winter I had been I've been working at a
local woodworking shop and this winter
by the calm that availability came up
for me but it has a convicted felon it's
really hard just to make ends meet a lot
of time for rent and things like that
and food typically wasn't cutting it no
other time that the job at that
woodworking shop became available it was
roughly mid-january and like I say I was
doing okay so what you've had is an
income problem overall okay and you
didn't have a plan to cover the income
hole in the winter and it cost you the
truck and the mower that's what it
amounts Trey okay they will eventually
come after you for the difference
they'll sell the mower in the truck and
whatever it whatever debt it doesn't
cover is called the deficit and they
eventually will come after you for that
and you can settle that with them for
probably 20 cents on the dollar so if
you end up owing them 10 grand probably
settle it for a couple grand you got
some old medical bills
you're not bankrupt you need income
claiming income if you had zero debt
today right you have an income crisis
don't you absolutely do one that causes
a lot of anxiety
I'm trying to figure out like I said ah
you know but a decade ago I did make
some stupid decisions and so I am a
felon you know but that is my past but
uh Who I am today
greetings for years to say that as you
know can be very difficult because of
the application at face value you know
but I mean
there's plenty of people if you tell the
story that will hire you to do some a
lot of things to get yourself up and
going so the first thing is get like
five or six jobs that do anything to
make money delivering pizzas working for
hem azan delivering stuff
there's people hiring all over the place
tractor supplies hiring like crazy right
now and I think in a lot of those cases
if you sit down with a manager and say
I'm gonna fill out the application but
you know 10 years ago there's a mistake
on there if you wanna know the whole
story I'll tell you the whole story but
I'm clean now there's no problems now I
can deliver a pizza ok I can I can cut
grass for somebody I mean I can do this
and I think you can tell your story and
get past that particularly with small
business now you're trying to get a job
with some big corporation they're not
allowed to look over that stuff and
forget it but you know we're a small
business we would not turn someone away
solely because they had a ten year ago
felony now if they had other things that
our pattern in their life we might turn
them away but I turn them away for a
pattern in their life that is negative
anyway when we were interviewing them
and so I think that's what you're
looking at here but no you're not
bankrupt you need a you need an income
and so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
set you up with a whole bunch of stuff
Jim we're gonna put you in Financial
Peace University to learn how to handle
money I'm gonna send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book the proximity principle
and you need to jump on king Coleman's
website and look at all of his stuff on
how to get jobs because that's what you
need and you desperately need an income
you have an income crisis and Chris did
we run into that with a lot of small
business people where they borrow to
start their business and he borrowed for
a truck and a mower and it comes back to
bite them yeah and I think it's it's
difficult to if you're in a business
that's incredibly seasonal because the
fact that it's seasonal is not a
surprise you know in in landscaping and
mowing lawns you know that it's seasonal
but you have to plan for that and you
have to plan for it far in advance to
carry you throughout the year especially
with your expenses because it's not
gonna be different this year just like
just like you said yeah and sometimes
you need the way you plan for it is you
create other things to do in this
offseason right if you make wedding
cakes well you got a you're really busy
in the summer right
but probably not as much in December so
maybe you need to have Christmas cakes I
don't know I'm making this up tightly
but your mom I remember was in the
bakery business and so you know that
stuff has seasons it has holidays yeah
driving it you've got Valentine's in the
donut shop I you know you get a
Valentine's doughnut or you've got a st.
Patrick's doughnut I mean it says
they're you know they're staying with
the holidays all the way through yeah
and then there's certain times of the
year that stuff like that I know with
our live events typically our live
events we don't have them in the summer
this year we're going to because a bunch
of our spring ones got pushed right and
they're postponed end of the summer but
typically we don't do them in the summer
because people are on vacation and doing
other stuff so it's very seasonal we
don't do them in December because
they're on they're worried about
Christmas or not worried about coming to
a get out of debt event right or a
business boutique event which we do in
November October usually right in there
this year what is it this year October
October okay yeah and so yeah they're on
October 22 24 so but yeah we and we have
to plan around that we have to go that
income is not going to be yeah if we do
that that we do that event once a year
so you don't have that income in the
business boutique product line when
we're looking at how business boutiques
health is doing as a business we don't
have any income for that October event
amount anything in May right you know
why some but it's it's not much you know
are in March you know but now come
August September you know and when we
launched it last October if we saw a
bunch because a lot of the ladies come
back but yes we have very specific
things in that business that are
identifiable as a season and you know
just around there and you're planning
around it I know I've got some members
in the Academy that do landscaping yard
working and they transition to leaves in
the fall and after that they transition
to hanging Christmas lights for really
high-end homes and you can charge a lot
to put up Christmas lights like they
start at like $1500 and so that's their
service for that you know six weeks
eight weeks and they just adapt
yeah and Jim I had a guy put Christmas
lights on my house and I did not ask
about his criminal record all I wanted
and he put up Christmas law that's right
you know
didn't and so I encourage you brother
you're going to get past your past and
your past is going to become a part of
your story
that that is not all bad that you look
back on and you go alright here's what
happened and here's what I learned from
that process and so you're gonna be okay
you're gonna be successful in spite of
that I know it feels like it's hanging
around your neck at times but I promise
you you keep pushing brother you keep us
on you keep grinding